finally here these sunflowers are in  full bloom up at gilchrist the flowers  are two bucks each and you can bring  your own vase and you'll also need to  bring your own pruning shears apricots  garlic and carrots will also be for sale  the orchard is open tuesday thursday and  saturday 7 a.m to 10 a.m also leave the  pets at home for everyone's health and  safety they're giving a heads up on that  you guys have pruning shears you i bet  you do like available readily available  i know exactly where they are in the  house they're in the garage or in the  house oh in the house yeah do you have  any pruning shears no i don't i have a  lot of love to give and i would love to  be there taking that photo with that  nice sunflower behind me that's it just  go enjoy yourself two bucks you can  bring your own vase